a couple of quick things before we wrap
things up here uh first of all
i am the beneficiary of literally
hundreds and hundreds of really talented
amazing people uh and then i'm just the
nose cone of the rocket and there's so
many people to thank
eleven years ago uh i made the decision
to come to tbs
at the time people were really surprised
that i did that they didn't think that
would be
the move i did it for one reason a guy
named steve kunin came to me
and he's one of the loveliest people
i've ever met in show business
he's what the irish call a mensch and uh
we take words that we like uh
anyway he came to me and he said uh i
will protect you
i will let you and your people do
whatever you want i'll never interfere
and will support you 100 they
did that they did that in every single
way they never went back on their word
they were extraordinary and lovely the
people at tbs
were nothing short of remarkable none of
this would have happened i'd have gone
away a long time ago if it weren't for
them
so steve kuhn and i thank you david levy
kevin riley
dave wolcus sandra dewey brett weiss jen
cohen we love you thank you all so much
for making this happen
uh
i want to thank
i want to thank my squad they've been
with me forever rick rosen gavin pallone
libra keen they're the best at what they
do
and they take really good care of me uh
gotta bring up uh the guy who uh i met
back in 1993 i was paired with him
to try this crazy thing no one thought
it would work uh
and he's been my executive producer
since then and we
are uh brothers from uh different
mothers our executive producer
our jefe jeff ross want to give it up
where are you jeff
hi jeff yeah
he's busy
he was back there trying to get a
restaurant reservation anyway
oh no they don't have an outside table
all right well anyway uh
uh you know jack black brought up
something really important uh in another
era
a sidekick was someone who uh
sat next to the host and laughed along
and uh just sort of supported them
and um they were great in their way they
all had their special skills
and i i when i found andy richter he's
one of the funniest people
that i ever met and i put him next to me
and andy i
never said to andy you know give me room
get you know you can't get the laugh
i've got to get the laugh the rule was
always
if you think of the funniest thing just
say it and that'll get us out and he did
it a hundred thousand times he's
a brilliant man and i love him forever
andy richter
hey uh
actually they're chanting is gonna make
me cry
it would have been nice if you like fake
laughed once there were times
they were tired
[Applause]
i started as a comedy writer so i always
took it as a point of pride
i always wanted to have the very best
comedy writers and i did uh not
starting in 1993 and until now i've just
i mean
uh i i cannot express how brilliant
these people are
and uh i don't often know that writers
uh are appreciated as much as they
should be
i you know i know that there are awards
for them but they're behind the scenes
you have no idea the courage of many of
my writers
the ingenuity uh just the beauty of
their minds how they work and they're
also really good people
i've been blessed with the best writing
in television in my opinion for 28 years
so
really
shoe writers got a call out uh
uh i got to call out two in particular
right now because they're
uh true just amazing people who still
have kept this show going all through
the tbs years and that is mr michael
sweeney michael b sweeney if you're here
uh mike sweeney's here
and uh who's amazing and he's always in
the trenches and he goes with me on all
the travel shows and we have been
we've been having fights all over the
world about
it's just absolutely absurd and half the
time he's wearing his pajamas uh
and an old beat up chatham sweatshirt
because that's all he brought
uh and we're and and uh i love him i
just uh and i'll tell you someone else
uh mr matt o'brien
who is i have to point out
he's uh he's no relation to me at all
he's just a brilliant writer in his own
uh
in his own right but uh i always tell
people
that uh he's my uncle's son and we had
to hire him
and so many interns think it's true
and don't give him the respect he's due
and i
i think it's the funniest thing in the
world
but matt is great
there's a guy on our show who never gets
any recognition
and you will agree with me that he is
the truest warrior
he is the like and the bottom the very
bowels of the works the gears he's been
with me
i think he started with me way back in
the early 90s as an intern
and he is the guy who travels the world
with me he's the guy that makes things
happen
when people try and shut us down and try
and stop a shoot he does some crazy
thing
that's illegal uh he gets shot in the
leg but doesn't say anything about it
till later
he is the truest warrior i've ever met
jason chilemi yeah
everybody
we didn't think about this through at
all everyone's a creep that comes out of
the dark
like i'm just introducing sexual
predators on the show
here's another creep yes
here i am uh a brilliant uh
woman who uh is uh is is our blind
producer and makes everything happen
uh if if she left us tomorrow i would
leave show business because and and jeff
would leave she just makes everything
work she's a genius
sarah federovich
all right well whatever
hey uh i gotta give a shout out to
somebody this is very hard for young
people to understand
but uh um in 1993
when i was chosen to uh replace david
letterman
people thought it was a bat-shit crazy
stupid idea
uh they be they didn't know
me the way you do i had no experience i
really shouldn't have had the job
one guy changed my life uh lorne
michaels at starnet live
said uh he did something
he said i think that guy an nbc said the
writer
with the weird hair and he was like i'm
trust me he's got something
and lorne uh put his credibility
uh on the line he really did at the time
you can go back and read and and people
wrote
wow i remember reading an article that
said lauren michaels has taken
like the biggest gamble of his career
with this complete unknown for such a
big job
lauren uh saw something in me i'd like
to think he was right
and he changed my life and i i'll owe
him forever he's a great man
on a personal note a
quick quick shout out to lisa kudrow who
i met
right outside these doors in a little uh
improv acting space
um
in uh in in 1985 and
uh i immediately sized her up as like
one of the coolest most talented people
i'd ever meet
and and a lovely person when i went
through uh when i started to go through
the possibility that i might get this
job that was i must repeat
a completely insane idea and nobody
except lauren thought it could work
uh lisa lisa kudrow had more faith in me
than i did and she said
you've got to do it you have to do it
you're like the only one that can do it
i thought she was nuts but i wouldn't be
doing this job you wouldn't know me if
it wasn't for lisa kudrow so
big shout out uh
now i'm gonna wrap this thing up as best
i can
uh i come from a big family but uh i
gotta give a big shout out to my parents
who i think raised me right uh i love
you mom and dad
and uh they'll see this i think three
months from now because
they don't know how the internet works
someone will get them a film of this but
i love them dearly
and uh you know what are you gonna say
they they uh they
they they're just amazing people my
siblings uh
uh neil luke kate jane and justin
they never ever were impressed with
anything
they just i mean would you they uh no
they i'm not saying that in a bad way
they they just had a
uh they always treated me the way they
did uh when we were kids uh which was
shitty uh i'm a [ __ ] celebrity man
they're really amazing people uh they've
supported me in every way
it's probably not always the easiest
thing to be related to someone uh
you know like like me who actually can
ask for a living but
um they've never first second bought
into any of the
potential foolishness of this business
and uh they give me [ __ ] constantly
and uh i love you guys all for it uh
probably the biggest shout out i
i gotta give uh is um one of the most
amazing things or i'm going to say the
most amazing thing that happened to me
on this show
over the 28 years of the various shows
of the various nine
uh was shooting remote and i uh
i saw this uh woman on the remote uh
who's it was an advertising executive
immediately fell in love with her you
can see
you can see me kind of fall in love with
her on camera it was the best decision i
ever made in my life including late
night i mean she is the best decision
she's my beautiful super smart much
smarter than me
wife liza so thank you roger
and i'll tell you this is
this is how
whatever people think of me in our
relationship they quickly figure out
that lies is the smart one
and really funny and when we shot the
scene from uh
the the notebook where i kissed ryan
reynolds
she saw it happen she was there she saw
it happen and when it was done she said
well that ruined both of you for me
uh
and uh because of liza and because she's
so smart and such an amazing uh mom i
have uh
two uh just two incredible children i
know everyone thinks
um their children are incredible but
i've seen some of your children and they
suck
my children are better they just are you
know i've really looked into it you got
some bad children uh nevin beckett i
love you and again you'll see this in 30
years when you start to understand about
my career uh
uh and then i'll just close with this
one thought i have devoted all of my
adult life
all of it uh to pursuing this uh
strange phantom intersection between
smart and stupid
um and there's a lot of people that
believe
the two cannot coexist uh but god
i will tell you uh it is something that
i believe religiously
i think when smart and stupid come
together it's very difficult but if you
can make it happen i think it's the most
beautiful thing
in the world uh i am so grateful to all
my staff and the fans in this country
and around the world
who have joined me in this really crazy
and seemingly
pointless pursuit uh to do things that
are kind of stupid but have something
smart in there somewhere and then
there's a little tiny
sort of flicker of what is a kind of a
magic i think that's what i believe so
my advice to anyone watching right now
and it's not easy to do it is not easy
to do it's not easy to do but
try try and do what you love
with people you love and if you can
manage that it's the definition of
heaven on earth i swear to god it really
is so good night thank you very much
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh
you thank you thank you thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you